all right i'm coming to you for help on
this i need people's opinions um about
10 days ago
we received a call when we were taking
live calls
from uh someone who claimed to be a
pro-trump individual who was formerly a
moderator on what's called the donald
the donald was a re a subreddit on the
website reddit that was so toxically
pro-trump and spreading so much
disinformation and so problematic that
it was ultimately banned by reddit so
this guy calls in and says hey uh i used
to be a moderator on the donald and the
guy spread even on this program
disinformation about ivermectin and
mysoprostol and okay we already talked
about that
i didn't think much more about it but in
the time that uh followed
the um release of that clip i started
getting messages from people
saying hey david we think that that guy
who called is ron watkins anne wrote in
and ann said hi david love your show
thank you for the quality work you do
i just had to share that the recent
caller who said he was a moderator for
the donald or whatever it's called to me
his voice sounds like ron watkins just
wondering and then another viewer wrote
in evan who said the donald equals ron
watkins hey david love the show as my
sister says after i shared a few videos
he is so astute and cute too okay
i just listened to the new upload
regarding tricked by a trumpist the
caller sounds just like ron watkins the
alleged 4chan cuanon leader and also the
guy running for arizona's congressional
second district could this be the same
guy
and i have to tell you i went back and
listened to it
and there's definitely a similarity
let's listen to the voice this is ron
watkins during a recent debate this is
the q anon guy
running in arizona he made that really
strange opening statement listen to his
voice here and i will make sure that
your rights are
are kept
thank you okay
here's one more clip ron watkins listen
to the voice ron some people say that a
lot of this was stoked by q anon what is
your relationship with q a not i have no
relationship with q anon none at all
none at all um the reports are that your
bulletin board sites hosted postings
that launched and launched a q a on
conspiracy so i ran a free speech
website and i was the administrator
and there were many thousands of
thousands of people that posted on those
sites uh q was just one of those and i
do not know who it was and i'm not that
okay so that that's the voice of ron
watkins
now let's listen to the voice of the guy
who called me all right tell me if you
think this is the same person let's go
next to uh let's go to rich from
illinois rich welcome
hi david hello
um so i was the top mod of the donald on
reddit for years until just before it
was banned
and with elon buying twitter do you
think that there will be a general shift
in policy
for the uh the tech places um towards
allowing things
like medical misinformation
there's definitely a similarity the guy
said his name is rich rather than ron
okay
i guess you could give a different name
what do you think is it possible that
this is the same guy it's a very
interesting question and multiple people
wondering let's listen to a little bit
more such as ivermectin and what
vice's motherboard did yesterday with uh
tweeting out the mysoprostol for
abortion pills
i don't know guys that it is very very
interesting there is absolutely some
kind of similarity but
first of all
in the middle of a congressional
campaign i don't know why ron watkins
would be calling this show
secondly i don't know why he would use
the name rich i don't know i mean maybe
he would maybe there's a good reason why
he would maybe it's logical that he
would because he's running a
congressional campaign
but it is very interesting and that call
generating so much content and now
people saying it sounds like the q guy
so let me know what you think i don't
have any other particular information
about it but it is certainly very
interesting